hey what's up guys my name is vashanoo
and welcome back to my c++ series so
today we're going to be taking a look at
conditionals in other words if
statements if if-else else is everything
now I know that for a lot of you you
might think that you already know
everything there is to know about if
statements and out statements and all of
that kind of branching behavior in C++
but I do encourage you to still watch
the video because you might learn
something new I'm actually going to go a
little bit deeper as to how it works in
C++ so so it's worth hanging around
right so what I mean by conditions or if
statements or branching what what is all
of this basically there are certain
times when we write our programs that we
want to evaluate a certain condition and
then decide what could we want to
execute as a result of that evaluation
so for example let's say we have a
variable called X and is equal to 5 we
want to be able to write code that does
something specific if that value is
equal to 5 that's essentially what a
condition is the condition is is X equal
to 5 and then based on that we can
branch to the appropriate branch of code
so there's actually two things that
happen when we write an if statement and
when we run that code there's the
evaluation of the actual condition and
then there's the branch depending on
that evaluation so in other words if our
condition evaluates is true we need to
jump to a certain part of our source
code if the evaluation is false we need
to jump to another part of our source
code and of course I'm saying source
code but in a running application it
really means machine instructions so in
other words we branch to one section of
our machine code our CPU instructions or
we branch to another section of our CPU
instructions now when we start an
application that entire application
along with all of its modules gets
loaded into memory so basically all
those instructions that make up our
program are now stored in memory and
when we have a condition that results in
a branch we're basically telling the
computer hey jumpsuit this part of our
memory and start executing our
instructions from there because of all
that jumping around memory and branching
this is actually a little bit more
complicated than my seam and there are
quite a few things here that are worth
exploring for example the fact that we
actually have to check a condition and
then jump to a different portion of our
memory and start executing instructions
from there actually means that if
statements and
branches in general do carry a little
bit of overhead and if you're trying to
write very fast code you might decide
not to use if statement at all in fact a
lot of optimized code will specifically
avoid branching avoid experiments
because by doing so it's going to slow
the program down eventually in this
series we are going to be taking a look
at some examples of optimization by
doing things like them removing branches
but that's just the way too early right
now I mean I've got some huge plans for
this series so you're going to want to
you're going to want to stay tuned
anyway without complicating this too
much remember a condition which at a
condition that's our if statement if
something is true then we want to jump
or execute a certain bunch of code
that's basically all there is to it so
example time I've got this very basic
application that we've been using for
like the last few episodes or so I'm
going to add a very base if there menu
let's have it
let's have that X example let's have int
x equals 5 and then let's say hey I only
want to print hello world if X is
actually equal to 5 so what I can do to
make that happen is just type in s and
then the condition that I want now in
order for us to actually facilitate that
condition in order for us to actually
check to see is X equal to 5 we actually
have to perform something called in
comparison in other words this is
something where we compare one value to
another and that actually is a type of
bullying statement so in other words if
the type of true or false statement X
will either be 5 or it won't be so we
get true or false now if we wanted to
store a boolean statement we know that
we can use the bull data type so I can
type in something like bull comparison
results equals x 5 now this this
operator over here this double equal
sign is called an equality operator it's
basically going to check to see if X is
equal to 5 if it is equal to 5 the
result of this comparison will return
true however if X is not 5 we will get
false so once this line of code gets
executed comparison result will be
either true or false
depending on that value of x now the
reason that this operator works the way
that it does is because it's been
overloaded in the c standard library
donna was someone has written a function
that says I'm going to accept two
integers and then I'm going to check the
memory of
to integers to make sure that they are
equal and if they are I'm going to
return true that's really all there is
to it all these operators that you see
in C and C++ they're not like magic or
anything
they've been implemented in a certain
way in that standard library in the case
of something like an integer in fact in
most primitive data structures really
all you're doing when you check to see
if if two integers for example a equal
is you're basically grabbing their 4
bytes of memory that they take up and
just comparing each byte each bit of
that memory has to be equal to that
other variable in order for this integer
to be equal so finally we can use that
comparison result over here inside our
if statement to say that in comparison
result is true now there's two ways we
could raise this we could write if
comparison results equals equals true
however that's not necessary because if
we just put this comparison results if
we just write if comparison result
that's going to give us the same effect
as if we write true so in other words if
composite result isn't true then it's if
seaman will not run we then need to
specify some kind of body in for this if
statement so in other words where do we
branch to what happens what code you
want me to run if that condition is true
so we can create a body here and put in
that log function and there you go we've
now created a branch
so if comparison result is true we're
going to print hello world to the
console otherwise we're not going to now
there are quite a few interesting things
that can actually talk about even with
with this little code that we've written
because there's just so much that's
going on here so let's just kind of let
us kind of run this program first see
what happens and we'll kind of walk
through it line by line so if I hit f5
right now to run my program you can see
that I do get that hollow world however
if I change X to be something like 6 and
I hit f5 nothing's actually going to be
printed if we put a breakpoint here now
I tell the breakpoints and debugging in
my previous video so if you haven't
check that out you're going to want to
check that out it'll be like a little
thing on the screen or something link
will also be in the description we're
using a lot of techniques from that
video in this video so you're going to
want to check that out I'm going to hit
f5 now with my breakpoints set let's
just close this memory view here and
then I'm going to hit as 10 we're going
to see that X is in fact equal to 6
where of course comparing it C is years
x 5 of course it's not 5 so if I hit f10
person result will be set default and
finally but hit f10 over here on this if
statement it will evaluate that if
statement and you can see it it jumps
right to this and get so it's never
crossed this line of code if this line
of code was never caught because we've
basically said hey only log hello world
if comparison results true if we want to
take a look deeper into the
behind-the-scenes of what's actually
happening here what CPU instructions
were running we could compile this to
assembly and inspect the absolute sembly
however there's actually one more thing
we could do as part of debugging and
that is use a disassembly of this
current earning code so if we hit f5 to
run our program with a breakpoint set
what I can do is right click here this
is once my application spawns right I
can right click here and select go to
disassembly and then you can see I jump
into this view where we have both our
source code and then the associated
assembly instruction that is that source
code so in other words our compiler has
compiled this source code into this line
and this source code into all of these
instructions and we can actually step
through this assembly line by line and
even take a look at what the registers
in our CPU actually contain so it's
pretty cool this disassembly views
actually amazingly useful when you're
trying to debug either source code that
you don't have access to some rewards
the after results to actually debugging
CPU instructions that's an absolute
nightmare
by the way trying to avoid that as much
you can but also it's really useful to
quickly see what code the compiler has
actually generated in instead of setting
up that whole outputting to a file stuff
that I covered in my how to people
compiler works video instead of setting
all that up we can just kind of look at
the disassembly view and so back here
you can see that the first thing that's
happening here now I'm not going to I'm
not going to just spend half an hour now
teaching you guys assembly I do I do
intend to make some videos on that in
the future I think you guys want that
you can leave a comment below because I
get asked this a lot but basically I'm
not going to spend a bunch of time now
explaining how everything works and it's
going to kind of gloss over this so if
you are interested and you want to learn
more you can either google it or you can
drop comment below and I'll try and make
a video sometime soon in the future but
if we look at this code you can see that
what's happening here is we're actually
loading a register with certain value
this move instruction more basically
means move we're moving the values
six into this register right so you can
think of this as we're setting that act
variable to be sick if we here at ten
we'll get that we'll get to the next
instruction now this is our actual
bullying stance right so what we're
doing is we're actually loading five
into that same register now this is
interesting because the compiler has
decided to do some pretty fancy things
with our code so if we keep reading this
the next instruction is going to be a J
and E which means jump not equal so in
other words if this comparison fails
right right now this comparison all
you're doing is comparing those two
values five and six if they're not equal
we're going to be jumping to this memory
address now the memory address is
actually this value here there are 1 b 5
9 b 7 right so if we just look at the
end of that early 9 b 7 you can see that
it's actually this line of code so if
these are not equal we're going to jump
to this line of code now when we know
that it's not equal so if i hit f10 you
can see that our instruction pointer so
this yellow arrow is actually what our
CPU is executing
it's jumped to that memorator asset o to
give your next instruction which is
going to be moving a certain value in
this case 0 into this register now this
register which is EBP which is an actual
register minus a certain offset here
we're going to be loading the values 0
into it now this comes back to what
bullying are when I talk about variables
and C++ in that video which you're also
going to want check out if you haven't I
talked about the fact that a bullying is
essentially a one byte data type and
like any data type of course there's no
concept of true or false in C++ so how
do bullies even work basically if the
value is zero then it's false and if the
value is anything but zero the value is
crude again we're just dipping with
numbers computers deal with numbers here
but because we've got that huge one bite
of addressable memory and if we create a
boolean is actually going to occupy one
byte of memory we don't necessarily have
to make sure that that one bit is set to
one so like it's really if anything
there is not zero then it's going to be
true right if we if we were just dealing
with one bit of course we'd only have
two possible values 0 & 1 and if it was
0 it would be false in this one it will
be true however since we have such a
such a big range of numbers
we can safely say that even if the value
is say 100 that's also going to be true
of course and just zero will actually be
false so that being said what's actually
happening here is we're loading zero
into that register so we're assigning
zero into that into that bullying so
false is zero get that into your head
false is zero and true is usually one if
we explicitly load a value in it will
probably be one however there's nothing
really that that that actually sources
us to be setting one it could be
anything right so false is actually zero
true is actually one asterisk so so this
move instruction is loading zero into
that memory which is equal to false
right so it's basically setting that
bullying to fault because of comparison
failed if we keep going here there's
going to be some other kind of code that
we don't really care about and finally
we get to the if instruction so what
we're doing in the S instruction is
again we're just loading certain values
each of the EAX register we're testing
to see if that EAX register actually
passes our conditions now this test
instruction is going to basically
perform an add a bitwise and operation
on those two registers I don't want to
get too in-depth into this but basically
if this test operations succeeds you can
see that we're going to jump equal so in
other words if that test operation is is
true we're actually going to be jumping
to the memory that is 90 F which is
actually this line of code here so it's
get past that actual logging if this is
not the case right so we don't jump
equal so we only the fact that it says
it's not a regular jump instruction
right which is JMP it's jump equal so
it's only if the conditional jump
statement so in other words if this
fails then which is going to advance to
the next line of code which is here rise
the next TP instruction which is
actually going to do a little bit
however we know that this test is going
to succeed because converse and result
is false and so if we hit f10 you can
see we actually do jump over here and we
continue running our program kind of as
normal all right so it's kind of a
deeper look at what actually happens
behind the scenes the new statement now
keep in mind I am compiling this and
running this in debug mode which means
that it's not going to optimize our code
at all so if we
that's our code we can see that all of
this can actually really be simplified
the compiler knows that this variable ax
is hard 26 we're doing comparison to
five it can actually do that itself we
don't have to do that comparison at
runtime we can actually see here's six
equal to five we can do that at compile
time and so something called constant
folding will happen so it'll turn this
all into a constant variable because it
is a constant variable all of its know
in a compile time and then it's going to
actually get rid of this if comparison
result if statement all together and
leave us with just STD see and I get
like it'll just remove basically lines 6
through 11
because they're never going to run so
why compile them why do that why do that
conditional check at run time that's
just going to take extra time and we
clearly don't need it keep in mind if
you if you're trying to play around with
this and see how things work by looking
at the business emply just make sure
you're in debug mode and make sure
you've got optimization turned off as
much as possible because if you don't
the compiler will do it will perform
some of this magic and you'll just get
rekt all right so back to this we know
that this comparison result is it's a
boolean right and a boolean is really
just basically an integer right it's
going to be 0 for false than anything
else such as 1 for true so what does if
statement is actually doing is it's
checking to see hey is this number 0
right if it is zero then that's it's not
going to perform that if statement
however if it is anything other than 0
such as 1 it is going to jump into that
if statement that's kind of why this
whole thing works and we don't have to
do something like equals equals true
because we don't need to be checking hey
is it equal to 1 or is it equal to true
or anything like that we can just kind
of say hey is this value not 0 that's
really what this is doing is saying take
a look at the memory behind comparison
results right what is comparison results
is it 0 if it's not 0 then execute is
code if it is 0 do not that is what an
if statement boils down to so for
example if I just write F 1 over here
and run my code it's going to compile
just fine and you're going to see that
HelloWorld does actually get printed
right and if I type F 0 then it's not
pretty simple we already know that it
works that way with this comparison
result of course we don't need to store
this in a variable
and I did this was I just wanted to show
you guys that this condition is is
actually a bullying type you can just
write if x equals equals five over here
and that will sink your code quite a bit
if our if statement is just one line of
code as well we don't need to provide
curly brackets for a body we can just
write something like this and it will be
fine you can even form out this some
people format this to be on one line I
personally do not do that it's a little
bit annoying one it's on one line
because if you're trying to debug so for
example if I put a breakpoint here
you're going to see that it's actually
going to hit this line and I have no
idea if it's actually doing the
comparison or if it's actually logging
the function if I hit f10 is just going
to go past I have no idea what's going
on whereas if I do separate it out into
two lines like this I can actually check
you can see that if I get at ten look
it's not going to that line so clearly
that line has not been executed nice and
simple
because bullying's are just a numeric
values and because it's if statement is
basically just checking something
numerically you can do some pretty
interesting things with if statements
for example I can just write if X right
and then if I run that code it's going
to basically be again evaluating hey is
is X zero or is it not and of course X
is 6 so if I hit us and we're going to
jump into that log function and actually
perform that that log it's also very
common to use this trick with pointers
so if we want to check to see if a
pointer is null null of course is 0 we
can just basically put that pointer in
an F statement condition like this and
see and see if it's null or not so in
other words if I had a pointer for
example const char pointer equals hello
I could just say is pointer log pointer
and if I run this code you can see
pointer is actually touching something
it's not null and because of that we're
going to be able to print that to the
console over here okay at this point it
was equal to null so it could be 0 or
null pointer or whatever you want to
type you can see that this code will not
run okay so basically instead of writing
if pointer does not equal null pointer
we can be a little bit more concise and
just write each pointer that is more of
a matter of style as well some people do
like to be explicit because they claim
that it makes the
more readable I personally don't mind I
usually end up writing code like this
because to me it makes sense right this
pointer is basically a valid value hey
do this right keep secure nice and clean
and something that you can do in C++
that you can't really do in other
languages such as Java or C sharp so
they're a little bit more explicit but
it still applies again it's kind of a
raw language right so anything really
goes now if we want to do something else
right so basically I'm saying here if
pointer is a valid value right if it's
not null then log but what if I want to
run some code that only happens if this
is not the case right that's why an else
statement comes in so I can write L log
pointer is null right and then if I run
my program right now you can see what's
going to happen it's going to print
pointer is null of course because if I
step through this line by line by using
the debugger the pointer is going to be
null or zero it's not going to perform
this and it's going to jump right to the
out pretty cool now similarly we can
also use LTS to keep checking for
conditions so in other words I could
check to see its point that is equal to
hello or something like that and then
maybe a log pointer is hello right and
what's going to happen is because this
is an else if it's actually only going
to check this condition if this one
fails right so the code that I've
written here would theoretically never
run right or at least this part would
never run because it's pointer was not
null then this disk would catch it right
and this would not so again if I set if
I set my code to something like hello
and then I hit f5 what's going to happen
is pointer is going to be not null so
this branch this branch is actually
going to catch that and then if I hit a
turn you can see we jump all the way
over here because none of this really
matters right only do these things only
even check this if this first one fails
however if I had written something like
if without an else yes right then you
can see that it is actually still going
to check that and that's going to
succeed and we actually end up printing
two things to the console so just
something to keep in mind now an else if
statement is actually a little bit of a
trick that you might not realize is
actually that we happen
it's really just kind of cleverly hidden
syntax in a way so if we jump back to
our code what we'll see if I try and
writers else if statement is it is
actually it is actually two separate
statements it's an L and isn't yes
completely separate because check this
out
that is exactly what happens right so
basically we're saying without else if
it's just it's just kind of combined
into one line yeah right the same way
that were kind of combining this into
one line it's kind of like if we had
written this in a way right so again out
if just to just a clever little else and
then yes so basically what we're saying
is if this condition fails then try to
an if pointer equal follow so again it's
going to only do that comparison is that
else gets triggered which will happen if
this is false and then it will run our
code so yeah clever little trick I
remember when I found that out it kind
of blew my mind because I didn't really
I didn't realize it at the time I
thought else it was actually some kind
of just keyword combination but no L
this is literally just there is no else
is keyword in C++ they just there's
Elton as s right and all we're doing
here is were saying else yes that's
right
pretty cool all right so anyway I've
said pretty much all I can about the
basics of if statements and conditionals
and branches and jumps and all that
stuff hope you guys understand how this
all works so I'm pretty sure I covered
like everything if you didn't get much
don't worry I've made this very
complicated but on the other hand I have
shown you a little bit extra than I
think most tutorial on if statements
probably would have will be using if
statements everywhere in our code this
they're too real there's two real parts
to programming there's kind of
mathematical programming and logical
program unless I like to divide
programming into those kind of two to
two terms right there's like programming
where you can actually just do like
mathematical operations and that does
make up a lot in fact most fast code is
actually written by doing like
mathematical operations essentially
instead of the second part of
programming on the second kind of
section of programming that I call
logical programming which is all about
logic right so hey if this is this then
do that right if there's been that
that's kind of a little bit more boring
I'm not saying that I'm not saying that
it doesn't have a place of course it
does it's you can't write there is no
game written there is no there is no
real application or game written without
using if statements or anything like
that I'm just saying that in the future
as we kind of learn to write better code
you'll see that a lot of the cases where
you might have used an if statement I
would not write I would try and somehow
make some kind of mathematical like
calculation out of it instead of
actually performing like a comparison
and a branch based off that because by
doing so you can actually apply your
program down quite a bit
and if quote-unquote consider kind of
work code it might make more sense but
anyway I'm just going around I'm just
going to keep rambling on I'm going to
going to stop right here do you have
enjoy this video please hit that like
button you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram just to do so and if you
really like this series you can support
me on patreon link is in the description
patreon.com 4/2 Cherno you can support
the creation of more episodes of this
series as well as the early drafts and
even kind of there's like a nice little
group chat that we have going on flat
where we talk about stuff life in
general as well but we try and talk
about what actually goes into these
episodes and and basically you guys use
supporters help me plan these episodes
and make them as good as they are so if
you want to be part of that you can jump
in by going patreon.com 4-2 Cherno alpha
Matt guys I hope you enjoy this episode
I'll see you very soon goodbye
[Music]
[Music]